das parkett ist quasi die parallelwelt
des internets in der man anonym oder
unter kaufen kann und zudem ist aber
nicht ganz so leicht ist zugang zu
bekommen ein bisschen tricky
überlebenswichtig beispielsweise für
menschenrechtler journalisten und
widerständler in ländern wie syrien oder
china doch am tag netten tummeln sich
natürlich auch viele kriminelle hacker
oder drogenhändler beispielsweise doch
wie genau funktioniert es und wie
illegal ist dass das land tatsächlich
warum halten es viele für das vorbild
des herkömmlichen internet dass wir alle
täglich nutzen ihr habt euch dieses
spannende thema bei whatsapp gewünschte
bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts
herzlich willkommen bei pixum science
fiction
tja und jetzt so was kommt und damit man
kennt das der vater am ende des videos
grob gesagt ist das parkett das dunkle
netz an technisch abgeschöpft das netz
dieser schutz kann technisch gesehen auf
verschiedene art und weise ermöglicht
werden doch in der praxis funktioniert
das darknet über die anonymisierungs
software namens tor wirklich gesehen
quasi eine art tarnumhang die
amerikanische non profit organisation
also tor project hat dafür einen
kostenlosen browser entwickelt der
internetnutzer unkenntlich macht und
anonymisiert auch die identität der bug
labs seitenbetreiber mit der endung
onion die werden verschleiert die seiten
des staates können von den herkömmlichen
browsern wie firefox oder google chrome
nicht gefunden werden
genauso wenig wie die von den
suchmaschinen die wir täglich nutzen und
obwohl es das dagegen schon länger gibt
es ist für geheimdienste wissenschaftler
und so weiter und so fort immer noch
schwierig seine strukturen und die
nutzer und nutzerinnen zu erforschen und
zu analysieren
so weiß man beispielsweise gar nicht
genau wie groß es überhaupt ist denn die
adressen werden automatisiert erstellt
und auch über die anzahl der bug
netznutzer weiß man kaum etwas was aber
klar ist dass zagreb wird oft als der
untergrund des internets bezeichnet in
ermittlerkreisen heißt es mittlerweile
dass man hier verbrechen als
dienstleistung bekommt crime
es ist 12 also es geht um drogen und
waffenhandels falschgeld und auch im
cyber angriffe in einer studie aus dem
jahr 2016 hat ein britisches
forschungsteam analysiert in welchem
umfang das darknet tatsächlich für
illegale zwecke genutzt wird rund 5000
an ihren seiten haben sie für ihre
untersuchungen durchforstet die hälfte
der seiten
war allerdings leer die seiten mit
inhalten die gehört 57 in die rubrik
illegal
43 prozent der seiten dagegen stufte das
forschungsteam als legal ein
der britische studien ging es bei etwa
einem viertel der illegal eingestuften
inhalte um drogen und beim fünftel der
inhalte um illegale finanzgeschäfte also
beispielsweise um den handel mit
kreditkartendaten und falschgeld und der
illegale handel im dax sind
unterscheidet sich gar nicht so sehr vom
legal hier im normalen internet es gibt
verhaftet die via gps und ein
rückgaberecht bezahlt wird allerdings
mit crypto währungen wie bitcoins zurück
zur britischen studie um terroristische
hetze und dem aufruf von gewalt ging es
bei neun prozent der inhalte und um
verbotene pornografie bei 8 prozent der
seiten wie die studie also zeigt ist
längst nicht alles was im netz zu finden
ist illegal und so gibt es auch immer
wieder stimmen die sich für das parkett
einsetzen und seine positiven seiten
hervorheben unter anderem der chaos
computer club ccc deutschlands der sich
beispielsweise 2016 dazu geäußert hat
nach dem amoklauf in münchen wurde das
dach netz jahr von extrem von deutschen
behörden kritisiert denn der täter soll
sich die waffe über das mag net
organisiert haben dazu der sprecher des
ccc - neumann
das bedrohungsszenario sagt von
deutschen behörden gezeichnet wird ist
nicht sehr realistisch der waffen- und
drogenhandel in der realen welt sei
deutlich größer als im darknet zudem
betont ccc auch immer wieder das schaden
und nutzen des st agnes abzuwägen seien
für menschen in ländern wie der türkei
syrien oder dem iran sei das segment
unheimlich wichtig um menschenleben zu
schützen und die freiheiten der
demokratie zu bewahren oder zu erlangen
ursprünglich wurde das ist eine
tatsächlich auch genau zu diesem zweck
entwickelt nämlich um dissidenten und
dissidentin zu schützen die darauf
angewiesen waren sich zu informieren und
zu veröffentlichen und zwar anonymen und
ccc-sprecher neunmal geht noch sogar
weiter und sagt dass nach netz ist das
internet wie man sich eigentlich
wünschen würde ein netz ohne zensur und
-überwachung mit all seinen vor und
nachteilen und jetzt noch kurz zu den
legalen seiten des darkness die sehr
auch gibt da gibt es quasi alles was ihr
euch so vorstellen können blogs über
politik katzen technik nerd kam und eine
menge tutorials außerdem gibt es anonyme
messenger und
tausche dienste seit 2010 hat auf
facebook einen dort präsenz einige
medienhäuser wie die washington post
haben auch anonyme postfächer über das
dach nennt eingerichtet so kommen die
redaktion an die brisanten nachrichten
von whistleblowern wenn er also auch
dabei sein wollt der link zum tor
browser
der ist unten in der video beschreibung
wenn er als erstes neues zu den themen
cyberkrieg verbrechen im internet
partner und kryptographie und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video und zwar
täglich garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt
über mich in der redaktion vor krieg zu
machen und mit themen vorschlagen an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und so weiter
und so fort und zur begrüßung habe ich
noch ein kleines goodie einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
die größte cyberattacke aller zeit
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran